all right what up guys welcome to the
just parly things YouTube channel and
welcome to morning coffee thoughts don't
have coffee um but I wanted to talk to
you guys about a random observation that
I have had so every day I go to the gym
pretty much I work out like I don't know
5 six days a
week and I'll see these chicks at the
gym
and these chicks clearly like a put a
ton of time into working out they're
clearly in super great shape really
jacked like they've had to have spent
and I thought about it cuz I know how
hard I
work and I
think well these chicks are in better
shape than me so they have to be in like
like it has to have taken them years to
get this physique so why do women train
so hard just to look like dudes I I
don't get get it like like they've put
in all these hours and like hours and
hours training doing all this stuff just
to come out looking like a guy and I'm
not talking about the women that have
slight muscle tone or like slim fit I'm
not talking about the women that
struggle like that are chubby or
whatever I'm talking about the women
that are clearly in amazing shape
clearly could have built whatever body
they wanted to build
and they choose to build one that looks
like a
guy maybe some of the gym girls can
explain this to me cuz I don't get it
cuz my thought is if you're going to
take all that time and
energy
anyways to get yourself do a certain
point why wouldn't you take that time to
build a body that looks like a
chick I don't know explain it to me guys
let me know in the comments like the
video on your way out subscribe and I'll
talk to you next time